ja gut es geht um ein thema was ich
hoffe nicht nur mich besorgt aber viele
andere auch es geht um das thema
energiewende das thema windräder wenn
man sich den koalitionsvertrag ganz
genau durchliest dann wird man
feststellen dass robert habeck ein
mammutprogramm vor der brust hatte neue
wirtschafts und klimaschutzminister der
wir bis 20.30 dass 80 prozent des stroms
in deutschland aus erneuerbaren energie
also quasi aus wind und sonne und jetzt
haben wir heute gesprochen mit der
energie-expertin professor claudia
kemfert vom deutschen institut für
wirtschaftsforschung und die sagt oh
wunder wunder bis 2030 müssten dann muss
die zahl der windräder massiv steigen
sie sagt am ende wenn man das
hochrechnet wird eigentlich in
deutschland künftig jede vier stunden
sagt sogar dreieinhalb stunden ein neues
windkraftrad ans netz gehen müssen damit
robert habe und die an der regierung
ihre ziele erreicht andernfalls so sagt
sie droht ein blackout und meine these
ist und meine forderung bevor wir in
diese ganzen experimente übergehen aus
der kernkraft aussteigen bis 2030 aus
der kohle sollten doch lieber erst mal
versuchen klappt das überhaupt mit dem
windrad kraft mit dem windkraftrad
aufbau haben wir genug gibt es genug
freie flächen geht das so schnell und
dann wenn wir wissen es klappt dann
sollten wir die kohlekraftwerke dicht
machen dann sollten wir auch aus der
kernenergie aussteigen aber erst dann
keine experimente sondern erst aus brühl
ich würde eher recht geben aber das ist
es ist unangenehm ich gebe dir einfach
vor recht hier sollte man ja eigentlich
manchmal widersprechen können ich kann
es nicht ich möchte aber noch einen
punkt ergänzen und zwar hier auch den
punkt freiheit denn mit diesem
windkrafträdern ja das problem ist ja
auch mein hat ein haus gebaut man hat
sich diesen traum erfüllt von seinem
eigenheim und dann bestimmt jemand dass
ein windrad direkt gegenüber von dem
haus gebaut wird natürlich ist ein paar
kilometer abstand aber der wert des
hauses sinkt sofort und du hast auch
noch diesen schatten und das ist für
mich der zweite punkt auch noch mit
blick auf die freiheit da sie auch für
schwierig einen windräder es gibt ja
auch ganz viel gegenmaßnahmen übrigen
films könnte man es gibt es kein scherz
es gibt eine maßnahme im sauerland die
heißt gegenwind plettenberg zum beispiel
die übernahme finde ich heute dran
finden und selbst da ist die grünen sind
ja sonst so für vielfalt und selber wenn
wir über sonst über vielfalt mancher
seinen gern diversity sprechen dann
finde ich ist ja nicht ein wert an sich
sondern sollte ergebnis von wettbewerben
guten chancen für alle sein aber gerade
wenn wir über achten schutz sprechen
über die natur da ist vielfalt an sich
ein wert dass es nämlich viele pflanzen-
und tierarten gibt und dann wird die
plötzlich jetzt hintan gestellt dass man
sagt das ist eine frage von öffentlicher
sicherheit windräder zu genehmigen und
das soll nicht mehr abgeholt werden mit
den folgen für die natur es mindestens
ein ziemlicher wertung die fans absolut
wichtig dass das thema besprochen wird
auf der anderen seite möchte ich sagen
also wir sagen alle wir brauchen und
wandel in dieser frage und wenn dann
jemand anfängt und sagt okay von mal an
wir brauchen windräder wir brauchen
wasserkraftwerke wir brauchen diese
bauen jenes dann sagen wir um gottes
willen das und ausgebaut sie muss
umgehend
sei das geändert in deutschland ist ganz
kurz nur ja also ich finde da muss man
wo man habe jetzt auch mal ein bisschen
die zeit geben und zu sagen wie kann das
aussehen und natürlich sind windräder am
ende teil eines eines wandels in sachen
klima und wenn man ganz ehrlich ist wenn
man das nicht will da muss man nämlich
sagen okay wir wollen wieder atomstrom
ja das ist richtig aber ich lerne ja
nicht schwimmen in dem ich erst mal die
schwimmflügel nicht dabei habe da würde
ich untergehen ich lerne ja schwimmen in
dem ich erst mit einem gewissen schutz
oder mit zum brett schwimmen lernen so
das mache ich damit ich nicht ab glocker
und absaufe ja dann genau es ist also
hat u haft und kohlekraft kann doch
nicht sozusagen die alternative zu den
sonst energiemix heute habe ich habe die
wahl der energie muss sagen ich habe ihr
habt doch liege die sage und schreibe
ich doch ein schatten von windkraft hat
vor mir als informator wir müssen also
bei der geschäftswelt ist glauben kraft
er lag bei der geschichte ist weder
einfach noch ein hauch actelion dass wir
nicht wackeln aber unter schock sie ist
aber noch anderen tag wie heute muss ich
aber an gewinnt er heute herrscht ein
ganzer winterlich habe ich ihnen sagen
wie hoch der anteil konventionell ist im
büro fast 70 prozent der aus kohle aus
ketchup und aus kenn fast 70 prozent das
kann doch nicht die antwort sein das ist
wie gesagt ich weiß die auto- oder
verbrennen haben wir buddeln aber wir
wissen zwar klebrige masse
die
leitungen reden oder über die
speichertechnologie und viele von denen
die die für energiewende an einem
bestimmten wochentag auf die straße
gehen gehen aber nicht an einem anderen
auch mal für den trassen ausbau auf die
sind so atomkraft
ich bin nicht für atomkraft als
schwierig ist aber ich fand sie trauen
dies waren oder sind jetzt zwei
verschiedene fragen auch atomkraft halte
große risiken und große kosten treue
bestünde in holland und in deutschland
und den ausstieg über als die frage das
sind ja zwei verschreibe die frage ist
doch was eine animal ein energie loch
das ist doch der fans geht wird ein tag
wie heute 70 prozent knapp 70 prozent
der energie aus konventioneller energie
bekommen dann können wir nicht sagen wir
schalten die komplett annika und hat
alles aus dem europa und das ist nicht
nur der französische
vorschlag wie hartl hat mit neuer
doppeln dass wir nicht schwimmen lernen
indem wir erstmal die schwimmflügel weg
lassen sondern erstmal mit den
schwimmflügeln lernen und wenn wir
feststellen wir können das mit den
stimmen bewegung lasse mir die flut
gerne weg sprich dann schalten wir eher
die kohlekraftwerke früher upper dir ein
bisschen umweltschädlich sind besonders
und danach die zumindest was das co2
angeht saubere kernenergie ab aber was
wäre
ausdruck klappt das mit dem windrad
aufbau klappt das mit der solarenergie
wenn das alles klappt ich sage okay dann
gehe nicht als ausrede nehmen deshalb
prosperieren regionen gefördert in
meiner heimat die firma enercon die
wahnsinnig gewachsen ist damals
allerdings hatte die dann große probleme
und wäre fast pleite gegangen durch die
große koalition als nämlich die energie
einspeise verfügung verringert wurde ja
und das ist ja auch die große frage wie
sehr subventionieren wie die
erneuerbaren energien bis zu welchem
zeitpunkt heute bei bis sie sich dann
auch selbst tragen können es muss sich
auch mal tragen und da gibt es auch
viele probleme bei dem eeg dem
erneuerbare-energien-gesetz und es darf
auch nicht das ist es zum teil geworden
zu einer umverteilung in wahrheit werden
auch von oben von unten nach oben indem
nämlich diejenigen die solaranlagen oder
windkraftanlagen bauen können oder
verpackt können dann sozusagen auf
kosten der stromkunden auf dauer
garantierte gewinne haben sondern auch
technologien die man mal fördern will
die müssen sich irgendwann dem
wettbewerb stellen deshalb dürfen
subventionen keine dauerlösung sein sie
müssen auch irgendwann heruntergefahren
werden deshalb muss man da sehr
aufpassen es gibt einen unterschied
zwischen sinnvoller technologieförderung
oder klientel politik will irgendetwas
sehr schnell verstanden wenn ich jetzt
ich habe mein freund er hatte sich vor
zehn jahren ein angebot eingeholt wurde
sie solar aufs dach klatschen jetzt hat
er gesagt okay dass wir jetzt machen hat
man rufen das ist so exorbitant viel
teurer geworden und hat immer
nachgerechnet coaches sind das die
ganzen umlagen um die historie geworden
ist das ist halt immer dass jemand so
lagen den fenstern er die haare genau
wird dass die differenz gab es wohl
damals nicht und er sagt dass genau das
ist jetzt das was teurer geworden ist
mit der dämmung etc genau das gleiche
die heizungen sind genau um das teure
geworden was jetzt so funktioniert wird
ich fühle mich also ich sag mal ich als
normaler endverbraucher für mich das
schon bisschen beschwipst ich wohne in
hamburg in einem uralten haus mit ich
glaube es sind 18 wohnung drin wir haben
ölheizung und alles antwort diese will
hat so muss er weg der schwäbische
vermieter haben weiß ich nicht das ist
ja auch eine diskussion die am kleinen
stattfindet und trotzdem obwohl der in
dem stadtteil wohnen 80 prozent grün
wählt die haustür ist immer offen die
luft zieht durch die ganze hitze wie
heizen den nackten nachthimmel aber
darüber denke aber er musste aber
verantwortete du weißt weil das
spannendes wenn wir jetzt nehmen sie
ihre energie ministerin geworden in der
neuen regierung würden sie dann sagen
mensch denken vielleicht doch noch mal
drüber nach mit der atomkraft wir müssen
jedenfalls darüber nachdenken wie wir
die dinge hinbekommen wie es
funktioniert mit otto
keine denkverbote jedenfalls erteilen
aber ich würde so dass auch nicht nicht
ausbauen aber wann wir bestehende
anlagen abschalten das eine andere frage
und da darüber sachlich zu reden ja was
die jaaa klimaschutz first sind der
versorgungssicherheit dass es einfach
wichtig und darüber muss man mal ohne
scheuklappen über gaskraftwerk gerät
aber wir wissen dass zum beispiel die
dass das volumen was wir an
gaskraftwerken bräuchten also zumindest
dass das hergestellt wird deutlich über
dem liegt was bisher angemeldet wurde
2,3 gigawatt sind angemeldet wir
bräuchten aber rund 23 gigawatt pro jahr
leistungen wie sehr letztlich sagt frau
professor camper als beispiel wie
abhängig dann sind wir von putins
leistungen die dort kommen oder sonst
irgendwas entscheiden entweder wollen
wir kohle das würde ich auch empfehlen
ist nicht gut wir wollen brauchen die
einigermaßen saubere zumindest was den
ausstoß angeht kernenergie oder wenn im
wind sondern der sich leider die sich
beide leider nicht speichern dass er das
problem ist ja toll sonne zu haben ist
toll hin zu haben wenn man das speichern
könnte wäre das super es geht leider
noch nicht oder wenigen beispielsweise
gast so in dem spannungsfeld befinden
wir uns und wir können entscheiden ob
wir uns einen sicheren trägers berauben
wollen oder ob wir auf putins gas
angewiesen sein wollen ob wir sagen im
winter wenn kein wind weht und die sonne
scheint dann holen wir den kohlestrom
aus polen oder die atomstrom aus
frankreich müssen wir uns entscheiden
müssen uns ehrlich machen und ich glaube
das ist die entscheidende thema glaube
es muss auch mal eine europäische
entscheidung sein weil wir sind ein so
kleines land in amerika kann ich ein
staudamm bauen china baut stammend natur
hin oder her jetzt mal aber die können
so etwas bauen wir da werden dann hat
sie mal waren 10.000 leute umgesiedelt
oder so das ist natürlich wir können
ja auch europa kann nicht dafür da an
viel zu dahinter zu regeln wie sind die
wände für migration für einige große
themen brauchen für europa deshalb
müssen wir im übrigen natürlich das
thema gas und nord stream auch
europäisch denken und zwar
wirtschaftlich genauso wie
außenpolitisch wir müssen das haus
verwandeln konnte auch an unseren
partner denken